my heart goes out to the loss of life
but i've lost mine brenda is living with
unimaginable pain she was once active
commuting to work every day but now
getting out of bed
takes an hour she is one of millions sat
on our waiting list for surgery
i just i really haven't left the house
to be honest with you
um because i can't i've just become
completely immobile
after leading a very active life
as of the end of february 4.7 million
people were waiting to start
hospital treatment in england a record
high
one million patients have been waiting
longer than six months
and over 387 000 have been waiting more
than a year
for routine procedures this the
consequences of covert care
as these numbers have snowballed during
the pandemic unions say a lack of
investment in the nhs
has let people down invest in the nhs
so that we have enough staff
adequately paid on the front line and we
need to have a really
realistic attitude and understanding of
how long it's going to take
this is about years rather than months
or weeks to get through this backlog
for those working inside our hospitals
the situation is likely going to get
worse before it
improves as the nhs tries to deal with
new patients being referred for
treatment
and those already on the waiting lists
nhs
england acknowledged the pandemic's
impact despite a treacherous year
they still managed to deliver two
million routine operations
during the winter wave but with the
workforce already stretched
solving it will take time but tonight a
big promise from the prime minister
we're going to make sure that we give
the nhs all the funding that
it needs as we have done throughout the
pandemic to beat the backlog
and uh i think we've put about 92
billion pounds already
extra into the nhs this year and
we're going to do whatever it takes but
the nhs has done an incredible job
uh so far i have no doubt that they're
going to be able to tackle this as well
a billion pound nhs recovery fund hopes
to shrink the numbers
but millions want the money promised to
translate to appointment dates
so they can finally begin their road to
recovery ashna harinaga sky news